i was 19 years old i had a terrible
reputation for sleeping around and being
promiscuous and i came back home for
fall break and i felt terrible because i
just felt like i'd ruined my reputation
in the first three months of college and
so i looked at my dad and i was like how
do i get everyone to stop talking about
me like this like how do i get everyone
to to respect me and change how
everyone's perceiving me and i was
trying to figure out some story or some
marketing thing to like rebrand myself
and he said son stop being the thing
that they're telling you are be the
thing that you want to be and then they
will eventually catch up and it took two
years of stop being for eventually my
reputation to turn around in that
community at the end of the day i
thought it was something that i had to
say or something that i had to do or
something that i had to prove but it
really was just proving to myself that i
wasn't that person i actually had to
start walking the walk before the talk
caught up